I had like a dude in a bathhouse we feel
like trying to show me is his dick
because apparently let it out there real
spry is this your first time to the
baths are you like me I like it a whole
whole lot feel like there's been a boom
of these like old OC RPGs in recent
years and I love the first pillars of
eternity in recent games like divinity
been great and I was kind of a little
nervous with this one just of like oh
it's gonna just kind of be more of the
same but the sort of like the
archipelago and this one the dead fire
archipelago were you having your ship
has like really added this whole extra
layer to the game that like I think
these other games don't have where you
just have this freedom to explore kinda
like however you want and I think that
really like opens up this game in a way
that like other Z RPGs haven't right I
gotta SEMA I will make this quick I have
heard some marvelous tales that
regarding your benches in the dealer
would in fact you are the first dragon
slayer I have ever met outside of a
grave because I don't play a whole lot
of these games it definitely played
Boulter's game boys need to right way
back in the day and I've been dabbling
with all the new ones that have come out
I do find a kind of jesting I like to be
the original sent to starts in a boat
you're imprisoned in one but then this
one is the thing that gives you the
freedom but I mean the games are
fundamentally very different I think
it's spite being somewhat similar yeah
so definitely looking in yeah and I'm
finding myself enjoying pillars quite a
lot
maybe about ten or so hours in right now
and I have my boat I haven't named it I
don't know he could do that but there's
a lot of things I don't know that I can
do in this game it's the scope is huge
[Music]
and now that I can go pretty much
anywhere it feels like wow like I need
so much time just to like relax and
really soak in this world and when I do
have that opportunity that's when this
games really that's best right we're
really liking it a lot it is really cool
how the boat lends itself to kind of
going almost wherever you want to there
suggested areas but you were you
actually talked to me earlier about how
they have like a level sinking system so
you can literally just have the game be
completely open right yes something
wrong this game has like difficulty like
right though you know you go to a
certain aisle in it it's like hey this
is like five levels above you you're
probably gonna die and you could still
try and do it in in some case I actually
succeeded one time so like if you're
good enough you can still bike overcome
those odds but typically that's the way
the game kind of like gates it off from
like you being able to do whatever you
want but the game also does have like a
pretty robust difficulty so you can kind
of like adjust everything if you're just
someone who cares more about the story
and you can turn difficulties scaling
them on where it just sets everything to
your base level which I imagine would
just kind of change the critical path
the game where you could just go sort of
wherever you want at any time I would
have to imagine you need like certain
characters in your party or certain
events who have transpired to like you
know trigger like a story event yeah I
imagine the main of the major stuff but
as far as like just random islands that
was really high rank you know like at
how many days a year and stuff yeah good
gear and stuff it seems like you could
potentially just say go wherever you
want and even then put out that leveling
stuff like I'm playing on classic right
now the game is rewarding enough where I
I did do that and I still was able to
beat it and I got like a really nice
reward so the game like encourages you
to try and explore an experiment and
like see if you can overcome these like
mods
yeah I'm playing classic I get my ass
kicked whenever I try to afford
their boat maybe it's just like the role
of the diet like I'm getting like you
know really tough opponents or something
but the ship combat I'm able to succeed
in so I feel confident in doing that
that said it also just feels a bit
obtuse to me I'm not exactly sure you
know I can see what my boat has or I can
see the canyons I can see how many
people there are all right I can see how
my boat is positioned to the other boat
but you have this sort of like
turn-based command system for naval
battles that has me a little bit
confused like I I'm always making
decisions but I'm never sure if they're
the right one so often they end up being
the right one but I'm not really like
using any sort of like critical info to
make that it's more like instinct yeah
it's instinct it feels a bit
rock-paper-scissors where it's like okay
well he hasn't fired in two turns so I
should brace because he's probably gonna
fire next turn oh no he actually didn't
now I should fire and like kind of like
this balance of like I should get closer
so that I can shoot my my change shot to
destroy their sail so I can board them
like there is some like experimentation
like variety to it but you're right that
it you kind of have to like figure it
out for yourself there's a lot of
experimentation yeah the game has a lot
of systems not all of them are explained
like all that well but that's also part
of the chart like I feel it was a lot
for me to excavate out of this game
right but I'm still able to make
progress even though I don't know
everything which feels really good yeah
it's a really good time to kind of just
go through even though like I I'm also
kind of confused why I'm going through
it but it doesn't feel like I'm
completely lost at any point in time
which is great and yeah I have a hard
time kind of like not thinking of
divinity too while I'm playing it a lot
even though like they don't have like
the naval combat and everything right
just the way that that turn-based combat
system works it's a little bit different
from this but I like how it encourages a
lot more kind of experimentation I feel
like there's a lot more to the world
than him but they're both good games in
their own right and I feel like it's a
much more serious kind of experience and
I like that I can kind of like get more
enveloped into it
I feel like I'm more of a part of
something that's much more Houston yeah
I mean like one of the best things in
the game for me is like when I'm
traveling along and all of a sudden it
pulls me into a little cutscene and like
you hear bells rings and it's like the
gods like pulling you into like the
nether realm to talk to you and sort of
like debate amongst each other about
what they should do and you just sort
this pawn looking up at all of them we
need this all done with like still
images ride with you know pretty good
voice acting and very good writing as
well your fall wildly endlessly unable
to find your bearings or slow your spin
and in the distance above know behind
you comes an insistent ringing you angle
yourself toward it searching for the
sound those illustrations like pop up
all throughout the game and I actually
those are some of my favorite moments
because they offer these very like D&D
style like what are you gonna do like
one of the first ones you get is like
they're classic like you see a wagon on
the side of the road like are you gonna
you know hail them or do you like what
are you gonna do but then you have like
weirder stuff like I'm gonna go into the
sewer and I'm gonna crawl up the sewer
and then like come out of a toilet so I
need to seek to the second floor of this
house everything's very unusual like
automatically concepts they've yeah and
yeah ideas and locations and like the
what you just described
that's not way you'd expect from a
typical fantasy game and this definitely
excuse like the typical fantasy stuff it
starts off a little bit of that then
very quickly become something else
totally the darkness the seriousness it
all kind of works really well there have
been a couple like cheeky moments but
nothing that is like outright hilarious
definitely in the side quest to get more
to that I had like a dude in a bathhouse
who's really trying to show me is his
dick because apparently real spry is
this your first time to the baths the
cost is high but so in the delights I
might have the skin and bones of a
retired scarecrow but the waters bring
youth back where it counts I think what
I've been enjoying the most is just the
level of option
I have inquests I feel like every quest
I come across I have like at least five
different ways that can play out totally
like there was one time I was meant to
help a prison guard and she was like
look I'm in charge of the prison but I'm
also in charge of the streets and we
don't have enough guards like take care
of things because these other bandits
are somewhere else so I need you to go
hire those bandits like walks the
streets for us so I go and I hire them
and I come back and before I finish
talking to her I talked to one of the
guys in the cells and he's like oh I
mean the guard go way back she's got me
in here because she doesn't like me or
whatever and I return stuff to the guard
and I was like you know I feel like I
like this prisoner more than I like this
guard so I killed the guy and he was
like you know you've branded yourself a
murderer now but that said I'll help you
out on your boat if you want some help
and then it was like oh cool I can
recruit people by doing things that
seemed optional the game never asked me
do you want to kill the guard
it was literally something I decided
just to do want to win because I felt
like well maybe she has a key and I
could use that key sure if she did there
there has been no reaction after that
like no one is talking about me like I'm
a murderer even when I'm running around
that first area no one seems to know so
I don't know how that's gonna work out I
imagine like there's a decision you make
early on right where you choose to save
a guy or a creative items from falling
off a boat right there's no immediate
payoff for that if you save the guy I
think you've done the road they'll be a
payoff just like with this guard like
I'm sure down the road I'll run into a
boat who has someone who recognizes the
guy who was in jail and say wait a
minute
if you're with him and you're murder
like I'm hoping that happens hey fancy
seeing you here
I can't see much of anything really
apart from you
just endless gray what happened
there's so many like different options
yeah you can do and I think that's like
ultimately like why I'm so engrossed in
this game is I feel like it is tapping
into that itch of like an incredibly
well-written RPG that just scene has
like seemingly like endless options and
like you know amazing characters like
we've barely talked about like the party
stuff like I think the characters so far
are like really interesting and when
you're walking around and they're
talking to each other like it reminds me
of like old old fire games anyway that I
loved yeah I mean are you guys born into
the main story or the side story is at
this point in terms of like what's
pulling you along because I'm I want to
know a lot about the secondary
characters in my party and how they play
into the bigger story cuz right now it
feels like it's just about me yeah and I
want to know why they might be important
well for me at least it's like to my
side characters our characters from the
previous game right okay that's true
yeah I didn't play that
yeah and that's something I actually
I've also really liked weird divinity -
I really like it but that game takes
place like 200 years later yeah yeah and
so there's connections to the first one
but it's you're not continuing the same
character this game is like boulders
gate to where it's a direct continuation
you're the same character you have the
same party members it remembers all your
choices and so it feels like it's this
like continuing like epic like fantasy
saga with this one character and that to
me is something that I personally find
like really yeah like that's what I want
like I someone who like boulders game
like like Mass Effect or it's like oh I
can keep playing and like having it grow
and build over time like that's that's
what I look forward an RPG yeah so no
I'm not sure like do I wait for the
switch version to keep playing this and
in the meantime play the first pillars
as you suggested earlier today because I
don't have all that context the game
does a really good job of setting up
like or at least showing you what events
happened right through and through text
and they know there's some like minor
cutscenes stuff like I have an idea but
I don't have that personal connection
I'm missing that
I don't know hey you could totally get
away without it but at the same time I
think the game does what any fit from it
and the first game I think still holds
up really well it is absolutely worth
playing for sure yeah cool I've got to
run guys Luke that's the pillar